die bässe und draußen warten polizisten
mit schutzausrüstung auf den einlass
allerdings nicht um zu tanzen
die metropolitan police london hat ein
hinweis bekommen dass hier eine fete
stattfinden soll sogar eine runde
einheit und der polizeihubschrauber
kommt zum einsatz
dann das kommando die beamten brechen
die tür auf und stürmen die illegale
rave party einige party leute flüchten
über zäune 78 personen kann die polizei
aber festhalten und bestrafen
mit umgerechnet rund 225 euro pro person
insgesamt verhängen die bam geldstrafen
in höhe von mehr als 50.000 britischen
pfund also umgerechnet mehr als 17.000
euro wegen verstößen gegen die korona
vorschriften und der teilnahme an einer
illegalen veranstaltung 300 personen in
einem kleinen raum der einsatzleiter der
polizei kritisiert dass die beamten ihre
gesundheit bei diesem einsatz riskieren
müssen um eine party trotz geltender
ausgangssperre auf zu lösen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren